so let's say that i've got two different
data sets so the first data set i have
two another two
a four
and a four
and then in the other data set i have a
one i'm gonna do this on the right side
of the screen a 1
a 1
a 6
and a 4.
now the first thing i want to think
about is well how do i is there a number
that can give me a measure of
a measure of center of each of these
data sets and one of the ways that we
know how to do that is by finding the
mean so let's figure out the mean of
each of these data sets so this first
data set
the mean
well we just need to sum up all of the
numbers so it's going to be 2 plus 2
plus 4 plus 4 and we're going to divide
by the number of numbers that we have
so we have 1 2 3 4 numbers so that's
that 4 right over there and this is
going to be 2 plus 2 is 4 plus 4 is 8
plus 4 is 12 so it's going to be 12
over 4 which is equal
which is equal to
3. so actually let's just let's see if
we can visualize this a little bit on a
number line
so
so and actually i'll do kind of a i'll
do a little bit of a dot plot here so we
can see all of the values
so
if this is 0
1
2
3
4 and five
and so we have two twos and so why don't
i just do so for each of these twos
actually i'll just do it in yellow so i
have one two
and then i'll have another two i'm just
gonna do a dot plot here and then i have
two fours so one four
and another four right over there and we
calculated that the mean is three
the mean is three a measure of central
tendency it is three so i'll just put
three right over here i'll just mark it
with that dotted line that's where the
mean is all right well we've visualized
that a little bit and that does look
like it's the center it's a it's a it's
a pretty it makes sense so now let's
look at this other data set right over
here
so the mean the mean over here is going
to be equal to 1 plus 1 plus
6 plus 4
all of that over we still have 4 data
points and this is 2 plus 6 is 8 plus 4
is 12 12 divided by 4 this is also 3. so
this also has the same mean we have
different numbers but we have the same
mean
but there's something about this data
set that feels a little bit different
about this and let's let's visualize it
to see if we can see a difference
let's see if we can visualize it
so
now i have to go all the way up to six
so let's say this is zero
one
two
three
four
five
six and i'll go one more seven
so we have a one
we have a one we have another one
we have a six
and then we have a four
and we calculated that the mean is three
so we calculated that the mean is three
so the mean
is three
so when we measure it by the mean the
central
point or measure of that central point
which we use as the mean well it looks
the same but the data sets look
different
how do they look different well we've
talked about notions of variability or
variation and it looks like this data
set is more spread out it looks like the
data points are more on average further
away from the mean than these data
points are and so that's an interesting
question that we ask ourselves in
statistics we just don't want a measure
of center like the mean we might also
want a measure of variability and one of
the more
straightforward ways to think about
variability is well on average how far
are each of the data points from the
mean
and we're going to that might sound a
little complicated but we're going to
we're going to figure out what that
means in a second and not not to overuse
the word mean so we want to figure out
on average how far each of these data
points from the mean and what we're
about to calculate this is called mean
absolute deviation
absolute
deviation
i mean absolute deviation or if you just
use the acronym m a d
mad for mean absolute deviation and all
we're talking about we're going to
figure out how much do each of these
points their distance so absolute
deviation how much do they deviate from
the mean but the absolute of it so each
of these points at two they are one away
from the mean doesn't matter if they're
less or more they're one away from the
mean and then we find the mean of all of
the deviations so what does that mean
i'm using the word mean well using a
little bit too much so let's figure out
the mean absolute deviation of this
first data set so we've been able to
figure out what the mean is the mean is
three
so we take each of the data points and
we figure out what's its absolute
deviation from the mean so we take the
first two so we say two
minus the mean
two minus the mean and we take the
absolute value so that's its absolute
deviation then we have another 2
so we find that absolute deviation from
3 remember if we're just taking 2 minus
3 and take the absolute value that's
just saying it's absolute deviation how
far is it from three it's really easy to
calculate in this case
then we have a
four and another four
so let me write that so then we have the
mean or we have the absolute deviation
of four
from 3 from its from the mean and then
plus we have another 4. we have this
other 4 right up here
4
minus 3. we take the absolute value
because once it gets absolute deviation
and then we divide it
and then we divide it by the number of
data points we have
so what is this going to be 2 minus 3 is
negative 1 but we take the absolute
value it's just going to be 1. 2 minus 3
is negative 1. we take the absolute
value and it's just going to be 1. and
you see that here visually this point is
just one away it's just one away from
three this point is just one away from
three
four minus three is one absolute value
of that is one this point is just one
away from three
four minus three absolute value that's
another one so you see in this case
every every data point was exactly one
away
from the mean and we took the absolute
value so that we don't have negative
ones here we just care how far it is in
absolute and absolute terms so you have
four data points each of their absolute
deviations is four away so the mean of
the absolute deviations are one plus one
plus one plus one which is four
over four
so it's equal to one so one way to think
about it is saying on average the mean
of the distances of these points away
from the actual mean is one and that
makes sense because all of these are
exactly
one away from the mean
now let's see how how what results we
get for this data set right over here
and i'll do it let me actually get some
space over here at any point if you get
inspired i encourage you to calculate
the mean absolute deviation on your own
so let's calculate it
so the mean absolute deviation here i'll
write mad is going to be equal to well
let's figure out the absolute deviation
of each of these points from the mean
so it's the absolute value of one minus
three that's this first one
plus the absolute deviation so one minus
three that's the second one and then
plus the absolute value of six minus
three that's the six and then we have
the four plus the absolute value of four
minus three and then we have four points
so one minus three is negative two
absolute value is two and we see that
here this is 2
away from 3. we just care about absolute
deviation we don't care if it's to the
left or to the right then we have
another 1 minus 3 is negative 2 it's
absolute value so this is 2 and that's
this this is 2 away from the mean then
we have 6 minus 3 absolute value of
that's just going to be 3 and that's
this right over here we see
this 6 is 3 to the right of the mean we
don't care whether it's to the right or
left and then 4 minus three four minus
three is one absolute value is one and
we see that it is one
to the right of three and so what do we
have we have two plus two is four
plus three is seven plus one is eight
over four which is equal to
2.
so the mean absolute deviation let me
write down it fell off over here here
for this data set the mean absolute
deviation is equal to 2 while for this
data set the mean absolute deviation is
equal to one and that makes sense they
have the exact same means they both have
a mean of three but this one is more
spread out the one on the right is more
spread out because on average each of
these points are two away from three
while on average each of these points
are one away from three the means of the
absolute deviations on this one is one
the means of the absolute deviations on
this one is two so the green one is more
spread out from the mean